president-elect Donald Trump has named
veteran Wall Streeters Steve minuchin as
the next US Treasury secretary so about
that whole draining the swamp thing
Trump built his presidential campaign on
guaranteeing change for everyday
Americans who weren't benefiting from
the economy he said the system was
rigged and that he would end special
interest groups control over Washington
chunk also repeatedly attacked Hillary
Clinton for her close ties to Wall
Street
Hillary Clinton has friends that want
all of these provisions including they
want the carried interest provision
which is very important to Wall Street
people so it seems a bit hypocritical
that he'd named Steve Newton a hedge
funder and former Goldman Sachs partner
as one of his top economic advisors but
this is just a classic case of the
revolving door between Washington and
Wall Street where officials enact
policies that help the banks prosper
often at the expense of average
Americans the Treasury Secretary's role
is to advise the President on economic
issues this person is the president's
go-to when it comes to issues like
bailout stimulus packages collecting
taxes and borrowing money to keep the
federal government up and running so
there's a clear conflict of interest
when the Treasury secretary has such
deep ties to Wall Street minuchin spent
17 years at Goldman Sachs when he left
in 2002 his stake in the bank was worth
a reported 46 million dollars the Trump
wasn't a fan of Goldman Sachs or the
financial elite during his presidential
run as a global power structure that is
responsible for the
decisions that have robbed our working
class stripped our country of its wealth
and put that money into the pockets of a
handful of large corporations after
leaving goldman sachs minuchin ran a
hedge fund that played a significant
role in the housing crisis the fund
bought California Bank IndyMac in 2008
with Minuten at the helm IndyMac
foreclosed on 36,000 families in fact he
was accused of running a foreclosure
machine of course he's certainly not the
first Treasury secretary to have ties to
Wall Street after his 2008 when
President Obama appointed Timothy
Geithner he was the former president of
the Federal Reserve Bank of New York and
a man who helped engineer the bank
bailout Geithner got a lot of heat for
his role in the plan that saved Wall
Street but it didn't do much to help
Americans facing foreclosures and high
unemployment we know a rigged economy is
when the rich get richer and use their
money to influence politicians those
lawmakers create policies that keep the
wealth flowing to the top so with yet
another wealthy Wall Street insider now
set to make those policies how many of
trumps promises to help average
Americans will actually come true